There is so much you can say about Prince without venturing inside poverty.
He was quite literally one of the most brilliant guitar players in the history
of music.
He found creative ways to use his masterful production skills in the studio to
invent new sounds and ideas. Prince could play almost every instrument.
He touched with a supernatural confidence and stability.
His legacy did not just extend towards his own music. Either.
He starred in films over saw movie soundtracks,
championed female musicians was a sex icon in his own, right.
And even became a legendary comedy figure. Thanks to the Chappelle show.
Prince came up in the 1980s, the decade of access,
and while the other stars of that time like Madonna,
Michael Jackson and Bruce Springsteen might have been louder and more prominent.
He was content to quietly produce album after album and timeless.
His often timeless, his Prince was known as the popper one.
And here now is the story of one of the most mercurial and or inspiring
talents that.
I have a grace to music weld.
On June the seventh, 1958, Prince Rogers Nelson was born in Minneapolis,
Minnesota replaced that he would call home and feel a special connection to,
for the better part of his life. His father was John Lewis, Nelson,
a piano player and songwriter, and his mother was Mattie Della Jan singer.
The music was in his bones from the very beginning.
His grandparents had their roots in Louisiana. So yeah,
that region's culture to draw from as well.
His father took the stage as Prince Rogers and bestowed that name upon his son,
Prince didn't cath has name and gave himself the nickname skipper utilizing it
for the better part of his upbringing.
Prince also had what seemed to be epilepsy and suffered from intermittent
seizures though.
He allegedly told his mother that they were finally cured by an angel.
Music came fast by age seven Prince had written his first proper song called
funky machine on his father's piano. His little sister Tyco was his frequent to,
and they often performed around the house together that parents would divorce.
When Prince was 10 years old, though,
his father would buy him his first guitar crucial step and the young musicians
ascent to greatness Prince's his mother would remarried to a man named Haywood
Baker at a tense relationship though.
Baker would take him to see the legendary James Brown in concert.
Prince was also quite the sports star excelling in football, basketball,
and baseball, and making a name for himself in the Minneapolis sports scene.
In 1973, while in junior high Prince had a fateful encounter with Jimmy jam,
who would go on to become a massively popular record producer.
Jimmy was immediately taken back by the skills that Prince showed on many
different instruments and reflected on how he and Prince would practice their
own skills. During breaks from schoolwork,
there was a keyboard room set up and the teacher would give you London bridge,
or Mary had a little lamb and ask you to learn it. When she'd leave,
would put on the headphones and rip through these keyboards.
I was always blown away by his talent level.
I didn't want him to get behind the drums at again. He was nuts.
That was my awakening to his talent and genius.
Jimmy jam immediately saw something in Prince and noted that his work ethic was
unlike anything he'd ever seen. That power would cross again in the future.
Two years later,
Prince would be part of his first legitimate band called 94 East.
The very also consisted of Pepe. Willie, who was husband to Prince, his cousin,
Marty involved staff,
Christy Layson Barry and Andre Simone friend of Prince Prince laid down guitar
parts for the group. For some songs they were working on in the studio.
It must've given him the first scratch that he needed to itch because in 1976,
Prince made his first genuine studio demo with help of Minneapolis producer.
Chris moon moon began to shop the demo around your record company is but found
no takers.
So we enlisted the help of a businessmen friends that you had in town,
Owen Husney who likes what he heard enough to sign the then 19 year old to a
management contract. Husney now I have to get prints to make a proper living,
which he did at studio 80 studios in Minneapolis and put together a press kit to
start to finally entice them record labels.
They began to work Warner brothers and several other high profile companies
began to swarm around the young Prince Warner brothers was the label Prince
ultimately decided on partly because they promised him creative control over his
music. Even if they still retains the publishing rights in 1978,
Prince headed to California and the world famous record plant studio and made
his debut album for you of the nine songs contained on the record.
Prince wrote every word,
sang every lyric and played every single of the 27 instruments.
The album spawns a few minor hits most notably soft and wet Prince's
1979.
Sophomore efforts simply titled Prince was when things really started to take
off the album, went platinum had two major hits.
Why you want to treat me so bad and I want to be your lover.
And it's featured the first of his professionally assembled bands.
The next year, his or his third album,
dirty mind created in his own home studio and an opening slot on Rick James.
His 1980 tool, things were in momentum,
but that was still some hiccups for the young burgeoning stop offs. 1981,
his controversy was released.
Prince was offered a spot on the rolling stones tour during a stop in Los
Angeles. He was forced to leave the stage after only three stones after stones,
fans began throwing trash at the stage.
Still the world was prime that for princess taking,
and it seems nothing would stop him.
But even those lofty expectations were exceeded. The very next year.
[Inaudible].
Dublin Melvins are notoriously haunted markets and fickle to get consumers to
buy. It's a lot of content. Sure.
But it's also twice the price when Prince released 1999 in 1982,
it wasn't just the album title that was learnt years ahead of its time.
The music was absolutely stunning and record buyers agreed as the album sold
over 3 million copies songs like the track delirious and little red Corvette
certified smashes spurred on by the massive popularity of the music channel MTV
web print sent some of the first black music videos ever at Prince was not done
topping himself yet. However,
after officially christening his stellar backing back,
he sent him out to create a film and album combination that would change the
game.
And it did purple rain was the vehicle that sent Prince from respected musician
to stratospheric superstar. The film version was based loosely on his life.
And as the album sold over 30 million copies at one time,
Prince had the number one album song and film in the country.
Something that had never been done before,
not everyone was impressed by this amazing run of success though.
Tipper Gore wife of Al heard her daughter listening to one of Prince's songs
called darling Nikki. One day,
the song is overtly sexual and references masturbation among other things.
This inspired her to create the notorious parents' music resource center,
which began slapping warning labels on records in an effort to clean up the
industry and one parents about the explicit material that children might be
hearing.
It still could not stop princess popularity as a pop star and sexual icon
though. His albums and songs kept coming at an absolutely prolific rate.
1985 saw around the world in a day with the head raspberry beret parade was
released in 1986 containing Kissinger.
The album actually served as a kind of soundtrack to his second starring role in
a movie, the underwhelming under the cherry moon,
which principles so directed a claims or not,
that seemed to be nothing the man could not do and no a higher plateau to reach.
So he went back to basics and disbanded. The revel
Prince was so prolific in his songwriting and creative ideas that he simply did
not have enough time in one solo career. As far back as 1981,
he was doing side projects, collaborations,
and spinoffs with a whole slew of other artists.
He started a side project that year called the time during the decade of the
1980s, the time put out four albums.
And though the public knew that Prince had something to do with the group.
His involvement wasn't fully known for quite some time.
Morris day was the singer and leader of the group,
but it turns out Prince was writing and recording. Most of the songs,
the group released Prince was also involved with the more jazzy band in 1985
called the family that one album featured songs solely written by Prince and is
notable for hosting. The original version of nothing compares to you,
which was made into a hit single years later by Chanetta corner.
He provided the bangles with their smash in 1986, hits manic Monday, Sheena,
Easton, Chaka Khan,
and Sheila E all enjoyed some time on the chance because of songs that Prince
couldn't find a place for in his own discography.
When Prince wasn't writing volts full of songs,
he was assembling entire groups from scratch in 1981,
before he had even really gained much traction in the music world.
He put together an all girl group called a vanity six,
but that wasn't exactly the original name at first Prince wanted the trio of
females to be dubbed the hookers, but that didn't come to pass Prince dress,
the girls in high heels and lingerie and had them singing sexually charged
lyrics. They were a hit though for a short time.
It seemed everything that Prince touched just, um, to purple.
[Inaudible]. Now the Prince.
Without the constraints of a bands, he funneled two side projects, surprise,
surprise. He had those into a massive three LP project.
He intended to be called crystal ball Warner brothers.
Apparently didn't realize that Prince was pretty good at getting people to buy
whatever he put out. So they demanded he cut back his ambitions.
It was not the first time Prince and record companies would butt heads and it
would actually get much worse.
But this time Prince relented side of the times was released in 1987 and likely
earned in the most declaim of any record he had put out to date and those
records then knit timeless at one,
a whole slew of end of year awards and turns in may level of artistic respect
that he hadn't quite had previously not content to rest on his laurels.
Prince walks on more music and ball ways to reinvent himself.
His next project would be the black album and it would feature more gritty songs
with funk and hip hop influences.
He also plans to pull a Beatles move and release the album where they symbol one
color sleeve with no markings or words other than a catalog number.
Nearly half a million of the albums were pressed and ready for shipping before
print sand.
What he called a spiritual moment where he learns that the album itself was evil
and he shelved the entire project mid production.
He quickly changed his tune and put out what he thought was a better message
with 1988. Love sexy.
The last two years of the 1980s saw Prince Trier's hands at yet another motion
picture graffiti bridge, but unfortunately the film and the company,
young soundtrack album, where a massive disappointment,
which seems to start to reveal some chinks and Prince's armor and gave him a
little less clout and leeway than he was afforded by his record label.
He did make up for it.
Some with the songs he contributed to the 1999 Batman movie that Tim Burton
directed the album sold over 4 million copies and drew a decade of astonishing
career accomplishments to a close Prince of course,
was looking as a new start for the coming 1990s.
And that new start would include Prince's very name and what he called a
combination of the male and female gender symbols.
He drew up what was in essence, an unpronounceable symbol.
Some goals is the love symbol and the whole law deal led to him being dubbed as
the artist formerly known as Prince for a time, of course,
this caused a rift with his record label Warner brothers,
as they didn't know how to market some things that technically no longer had a
name. The label began to push back refusing to release the tons of music he had
contained in his volts.
His answer was to begin releasing massive amounts of new music with new backing
bands,
the new power generation at a super fast clip in order to fulfill his contract
quicker and be released from any more artistic obligations with warn app,
even appeared with the word slave on his face at public events to show how he
felt he was being treated.
And that's how the first half of the 1990s went for the artist.
Formerly known as Prince see released six albums of quality music that likely
wasn't marketed very well by a label that no longer had control of him.
What he wanted was true emancipation.
Now that he was free from the Warner brothers contract that had slowly been
stifling and emancipation was exactly what he was feeling.
And that's exactly what he named his 1996, three disc album in 1998.
He began emancipating some old material of his that Warner wanted no part of
with the five disc crystal ball in 1999.
He finally decided he wanted to reunite with a major label and to have access to
the tools at their disposal. He cuts a deal with Arista records,
putting out Ravens through the joy. Fantastic,
and then ending the millennium with an all star televised concert on new year's
Eve. While the decade of the 1990s was fraught with turmoil for the artist,
formerly known as Prince,
he had finally gained his artistic freedom and it was nowhere near done trying
on new musical ideas.
Yeah.
In two thousands Prince decided he was comfortable enough to be called by his
given name once more. He was still enamored with the love symbol, however,
and it's continued to use it in many forms,
including a gorgeous purple guitar Prince was utilizing new technology to bring
his music to the masses.
He was one of the first artists to use the internet to establish a subscription
service to release albums.
It was basically iTunes many years before iTunes Prince was showing more and
more how devoted he was to his fans.
Besides the internet releases that cut out a record label middlemen and gave
music directly to the people. He also began opening up his home,
the famous Paisley park studios in Minneapolis to concerts and tours in the mid
two thousands Prince played a series of performances that would drop drawers and
to define him for years to come,
one was during his own induction to the rock and roll hall of fame of special
notes is the Jamey joins near the end for fellow inductee beetle,
George Harrison, while on stage with Harrison son, Donnie and Tom petty,
Prince Uncorked,
a two minute guitar solo that left the entire stage and viewing audience flawed
in 2007 Prince was announced as the halftime performer at the super bowl.
When the second quarter ended a stage was unveiled that took the form of his
very own love symbol.
Then the next 18 minutes Prince had the majority of the world in his hand,
it was almost a storybook performance,
140 million people watched as the rain came down. And of course,
Prince took full advantage of the moment. Closing hours with purple rain.
Prince was still prolific with his artistic output in the two thousands,
including some eclectic forays into jazz on 2000 and ones, the rainbow children,
and to return to basic sounds on 2006 31 21.
And while he didn't have as many thunderous hits like he did in the 1980s,
it was always a maturing and growing and creatively munch of that decade.
And as the 2010s were almost a victory lap for Prince with defining performances
at venues like the Grammys Coachella and the Montreux jazz.
[Inaudible].
All go group in 1981.
So two D Prince approached the idea of having female musicians backing in,
in 2013. He dubs them third eye girl,
and he embarked on a few critically acclaimed tours with them for the next few
years and released a few studio albums in 2000 and Prince swings on the piano
and the microphone tour, which is exactly what it sounds like.
And he showed how well his material was constructed at the most basic level.
Unfortunately,
this is also when princess health began to decline on April the seventh Prince
up to cancel two performances of his piano tour in Atlanta citing the flu.
He was able to rally for his April 13th show, but on the subsequent flight home,
the next morning, his jet out to make an emergency landing in Illinois,
where he became unresponsive.
He was rushed to the emergency room and given a drug usually meant to revive
opioid overdose victims. It worked.
And then he left the ER against the advice of his doctors.
He made a series of sporadic public appearances over the next few days before
seeing a specialist and addiction medication on April the 20th in California,
that specialist sung was on his way to Prince's home the next morning with
medication to fight opioid addiction,
but was surprised to see emergency crews trying to revive Prince.
He was declared dead at 10:07 AM from an overdose of fentanyl.
Prince was twice divorced and never known to have fathered. Any children.
Music was literally his baby and the amount of left behind in his Paisley park
home volts is simply staggering.
There will likely be several more lifetimes of Prince music to come.
And it's clear that his reign is nowhere near over as the cup of water.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe several new videos a week on this channel and as
always, thank you for watching.